let's pull this story up from CNBC we
got this they're coming after Elon Musk
as well SEC sues to force Elon Musk to
testify in Twitter probe they're saying
that he didn't uh he didn't comply with
his subpoena to testify he failed to
appear on September 15th 2023 the case
is tied to musk's purchase of Twitter
last year and the stock trading
surrounding the acquisition this is the
game that's it that's the news if you in
any way stand against this failing and
corrupt establishment machine they will
in desperation do everything they can to
stop you but you know what I see with
this this is pathetic this is sad back
in the day we wouldn't get a story about
them forcing someone to testify no one
would dare defy them but you know what
I've been saying it's like they have
that saying that wealth only lasts three
generations well the people who created
the intelligence agencies and ran them
and knew what it took to build them up
have G gave it to their kids and their
kids kids and the kids kids have no idea
how to make the machine work and so it's
falling apart good riddens well and Elon
in his defense claimed hey I've already
testified numerous times about this
acquisition not only that it was
probably the most scrutinized
acquisition of a public company because
anytime you're taking a public company
private I mean the regulations to go
through that process especially when
it's $44 billion whatever it was they
are they are massive and Monumental and
so this was already the most scrutinized
uh acquisition in modern history he
already has been under the spotlight for
this and what really frustrates me about
all this is that the SEC is choosing to
have Elon testify meanwhile we still
have stuff revealed that has not been
dealt with from the Twitter files so
instead of actually handling the
corruption that was exposed under the
previous leadership of Twitter they're
wanting to subpoena the guy and Sue the
guy who actually is trying to bring all
that into the light and do their jobs
for them the SEC is a regulatory invest
or investigative body they're supposed
to be Gatekeepers and accountability
people for companies and yet Elon
actually did their job for them by
investigating malfant that was happening
in a public company so it's just it he's
the good guy here and he's the one
getting punished for this and he stopped
the distribution of online child adult
behavior on the platform when there was
victims demanding Twitter take it down
Twitter knew there was adult content
with children in in very horrific
horrible ways and they knew who it was
they had the person they had the child
coming to them saying please take this
down and they refused Elon Musk came in
and then finally told people exactly
what was going on he's allowing people
to speak freely and that's the issue
here he's actually doing something good
that allows people to find out what's
really happening in this world and
therefore he needs to be stopped and I'm
pretty sure that doj also opened an
investigation into Tesla was it yes and
like they're just harassing well they're
going after him for not hiring refugees
even though it's it's illegal to to hire
people who are not American citizens for
your company it doesn't matter what
they're going they're just going after
him they're just going after Mike LEL
they're just going after Donald Trump
why because they are all opponents of
the current system and it's dangerous
time and the Newsweek article came out
about how the FBI is going to be closely
monitoring Trump allies and Trump
supporters as we get closer to the 2024
election they are trying to intimidate
us they are trying to break us uh but I
think the people are waking up I think
Joe you know Joe Rogan was talking about
the marago valuation today he's like
these people aren't even trying to hide
their you know anymore like
like they don't even care anymore um but
the American people I think are waking
up we need to continue to shed light on
what's Happening and I think people like
Elon is courageous he's not going to
back down I think he's going to stand
strong in in the face of this President
Trump has obviously stood strong um but
it's sick and we can't let this stand
and I think whoever becomes the next
speaker of the house needs to deliver on
the promise of finally holding these
people
accountable yes how what are they going
to do though well you could start with a
subpoena how many subpoenas were sent in
so far in 9 months not not too many yeah
um and so bring people before Congress
the January 6 committee I think it was a
complete and total farce but they Seena
a th000 so-called Witnesses and in their
900 page report only like nine people
were mentioned but they had a th000
Witnesses they harassed a thousand Trump
allies just for the hell of it meanwhile
we actually have real things that we can
be going after and we've sent out like
two subpoenas and so we need to actually
hold people accountable and um I think
we have people on the Judiciary
Committee who want to get it done we
have people on Ways and Means and on um
oversight that want to get it done but
we just need blessing from the top and
so um we need to play by the rules of
the January 6 committee to we just need
a speaker Trump there you go and if he
flood the Zone like part part of the
thing is the SEC doesn't actually think
Elon would ever be guilty of any of this
they know this is all a sham they know
it's a joke just like they know Mike
Lindell nothing's going to turn up in
the audits he's a huge company that's
audited every year they do it because
they want to distract you if they can
distract the founder of Tesla from his
work they're hoping they can throw you
off course then Republicans we claim
civility so we don't dare flood the Zone
when we actually have legitimate cases
so we could actually bring forth
continual judgments multiple every
single day against these corrupt actors
and we don't cuz we stay civil quote
unquote and uh it's not a winning
strategy we actually have the case on
our side the truth is on our side all of
our arguments have the virtue of being
true and so while the SEC is more
antagonistic and militant than we are
they have no legs to stand on and the
opposite is true for us so that's got to
change this is the problem with Kevin
McCarthy it was once again slow down
there Democrats Kevin McCarthy was
negotiating with them behind the backs
of the Republicans there was no point in
there being a majority what do we we
have if the establishment Republicans
and the Democrats are the exact same
thing it's funny because the Democrats
are like here's what we overtly want the
Republicans are like hey all those
things are really bad all right is
nobody looking okay let's go vote for
those things we really want so it's got
to change and you know I don't know if
it ends up with Trump as a speaker it'd
be great it'd be a dream come true but
I'll take obstruction over them doing
the exact same thing they you know over
and over and over again nothing
happening I think I think outside of
that is the right for too long I think
one of the reasons we're seeing this
change is Donald Trump lit up a bunch of
people who normally did not vote and
have a different worldview than your TR
traditional conservative conservatives
were always like well we must maintain
decorum and play by the rules and then
Trump came in and was like Rosie OD do
is a fat pig you didn't say it like that
exactly but all of a sudden the cor was
on its head and regular people who never
voted before were all of a sudden
finding themselves align with the
Republicans Republicans got pissed like
well I never and so now you're seeing
Fighters you're seeing people I remember
I was in an Occupy Wall Street March in
Chicago and it was like one of these
ancillary like protests they were doing
and they marched through uh South
Hallstead and it was the funniest thing
ever to see these Southside irish guys
just start punching these activists and
it's like they the these leftists had
this idea that we're the working class
and we are right and the actual
workingclass white dudes in the south
side of Chicago were like you're the
elite scumbags causing our problems get
out of our neighborhood and they're like
no we're here for you man and this dude
just takes shirt off and is like nope
and I'm like well I certainly don't
encourage that kind of stuff it is
interesting to see these are the kind of
people that I think Donald Trump
actually woke up these are the white
working class who felt left behind and
as Michael Moore said Trump was the
human Molotov cocktail they were going
to lob into the system so now what ends
up happening is these people are voting
for the likes of mad Gates and they're
voting for other people like him and
they want aggression they want someone
to get into Congress and be more
aggressive and more assertive and make
demands yeah well The Establishment
tried to primary mades this last cycle
in
2022 and uh I they they put a lot of
money behind this guy I think like 2
million bucks or something like that and
Matt beat him 82 to 20 or 82 to 18 or
something like that it was no
contest like the establishment has so
much money to just blow trying to take
the heads of our Fighters and that is
why Republicans have such a hard time
like Blake Masters for example was such
a great I thought really great guy and a
great POS a great candidate but you
spent so much money fighting him in the
primary you had one establishment guy
who put in like 20 million bucks to
fight him in the primary and then the
general comes around and Blake Masters
is outs spent 3 to one four to one k
Lake same situation $25 million against
Carrie Lake in a primary under funding
the general the way it's supposed to
work is you vote for your Republican who
goes to Congress and says we don't want
you know these books in our schools and
the leadership says you you got it we'll
ban it tomorrow just sign War funding
funding for Ukraine funding for
Afghanistan and they go you got a bus so
there are certain things that you must
stand by and then you can maybe get a
little a little morsel here and there
and so we've got a bunch people go to
Congress and they're basically like
peasants on their knees begging may I
have another crumb sir from The
Establishment Elites who are like I'll
give you your crumb but you must give me
my billion dollars for bombs and they go
yep I don't want to fight it's too scary
you know so in this Republican primary
for
president both primaries democrat or
republican the Democrats have spent $35
million on ads and on the Republican
side $139 million has been spent
125 of that 120 million of that has been
against Trump and Trump is at 65% and
everybody else is in single digits now
wow and so and the voting doesn't start
for three more months and so we're going
to continue the establishment donors are
going to continue to light money on fire
because they hate Trump and then we're
going to be severely underfunded come
the general election because of the
people's selfishness and the hatred of
not just Trump but the people that he
brought into the party and so the
Democrats are just sitting back laughing
at these Jokers that are running and you
know the the finances are actually
incredibly important thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net